yeah welcome to this video I'll be doing
some nuts Cuban sing again and this is
keep it saying on the black player here
mostly this is Grand Master yeah so
Sarah one is of course really from the
United States a distal place for the
United States but he lives in the
Netherlands for a couple of years now
this is also why you see that the Dutch
flag here like of the Netherlands and
it's a three minute game I both players
are down to 40 seconds and I think um
yeah yeah science in trouble he's got
his rook down now for a couple of poles
but he's got an attack going against the
White King so it's um still I'm not so
clear at least in terms of a blitz game
probably it's nothing for correspondence
chess but in Blitzen this position is
still tricky for white is playing a
fellow American Laurie and if the the
flag is correct you you you don't know
it's um could be something somebody from
another country just using the US flag
for whatever reason okay so like ice
pushing the central pawns trying to get
them get some play going white still has
problems with the king of course you
cannot easily use the f1 rook for
something active and yeah this is not
easy end off a white and it's down to
ten seconds now Queen g3 threatened yeah
23 come on yourself yeah Quincy 340 page
one mate yeah this is neat and white
will lose some time
yeah Queen Adrienne yer know five lines
of work it's on time ya like like a
cyano llamada of porns up okay let's
hope for a couple of more games I just
saw that he was playing dumb yeah with y
tu very often place those flank openings
so yeah blacken ya t sixes in Kings
Indian style oh we actually transpose to
to some Dutch setup uh-huh yeah III 92
this is a very solid set up but not bad
at all it some more than the English
kind of flavor to set up it's not really
similar to to something that would arise
out of the the standard Dutch um yeah
what immediately tries to attack him the
central pawn wedge but surprise that
like allowed them I kept Johnny for that
he didn't take himself as III porn would
have been a target White has got the
bishop on a three already not on c1 ok
but like was intending obviously to play
e4 and e5 rolling up them a nice center
and white rice with g42 m2m to get some
pressure against the d5 so on it's a
very interesting play oops yeah
interesting hehe just just sect the
exchange to to get through there we are
ok have one or g6 it's very interesting
the bishop on a three also controlled so
DF eight square so that Luke f8 is not a
possible defense and now maybe just g6
is threatened
after g6 also d5a saying and also note
that the night on 86 is just stupid as
it tries to improve it yeah white has
multiple ways to improve the position
also just h4 maybe h4 and idea Bishop to
h3 to f5 could be an idea at just one
offhand suggest the problem really is
that the bishop on a3 is so strong and
it always controls evade any what should
like to know it's very difficult to
suggest a movie even 96 or wat die but
Bishop e7 hangs and at least mmm yeah
this is a very ugly to play just let us
chat message sorry yeah like didn't move
anyway and I can understand this I
wouldn't wouldn't be too thrilled either
yet to find a move yeah where you're
strong what what about d5 now yeah black
is this really is he cannot move
anything yes hard time moving any office
pieces i know i can just take you five
if you want yeah and what what should
like do not much not much what you can
do yeah Knight f6 serve as a possible
next move the only thing that is really
very semester is white skin position
because it's it's rather open of course
okay up the ship f1 hmm yeah e6 is
hanging it and and into e 6 88 yeah both
hanging so um I don't know what black
should do now I mean everything's
hanging and he doesn't have a direct
call to play I can think you can just
take it yeah now I probably at a key
form and queen horny for is covering g2
air black resigns yeah this was actually
very nicely played if you look again at
this year rook f7 this is very strong on
getting a pawn and and now you are you
have have really only good pieces left
the night attacking I don't have
examination Lord and nida taking d5 and
you everything's nicely controlled
especially f idea that black cannot play
rook fa this is super helpful and yet
got Queen f7 coming in this age for
Bishop h3 is also strong so on this is
very good compensation for the for the
exchange yeah unfortunately am p.m. he
just disconnected so only got really one
game out of this I can um check briefly
if we got some some some other games
going that we could could look at let's
see yeah we can um we can look here at
this game and follow the black player
here Igor Giro ef-2 yet this is some
problem yeah that's one page listing top
i see ratings and wear them very often
they take some educated guesses so about
the anonymous players and their ad says
that
should be am Rosa which I'm not sure on
which yeah which evidence is behind this
why this should be morose [ __ ] okay if
you look at this this is five minute and
this guy is rated 2800 which is really
am yeah crazy strong and we handed you
can compare this let's say um let's
change and briefly and what yeah I'm
sorry I just want to check quickly Janna
cameras current rating is 2719 so it's
80 points lower just for comparison so
this is 2800 is really crazy high okay
so um let's look at this if it's not
your also which um it's still a very
good player actually I believe if you
get to 2800 them in five minute it must
be 2,000 really am what class of very
Enya that this is simply too high and we
can also safely say that it's not cards
night not Kara wanna as they are playing
them in Bilbao at the moment all right
so we're here and what is this position
at some complicated Lex got two bishops
but a very funny pawn structure with h6
kind of solo type with them with lots of
hold cm but then white has the wrong
bishop to take use of the holes if you
got a wide scan wet LightSquared bishop
on a four day five then why would be it
would be great but the special bond g3
is very silly so black should be okay
it's not a big issue this this quest and
now it's got all porn some black squares
but it's a question how black how white
actually secure
d6 porn maybe 94 you need to reckon with
that 50 Bishop 360 he just grabbed a for
yeah this was also a possibility but now
night before I guess attacking c5 no
he's playing some guy from the US I'm
not sure it as a name in there no but 25
is not not too bad either 15 minute
closer to five as if I'm really really
good shape and I'm not doing commentary
then I can get to this kind of writing
but it's not easy at all I lose about
100 points in and strength because of um
comentarii on the gamers commentary now
I try to pronounce this correctly but I
usually fail yeah okay white plate aids
h4 try to libel away at this point and
maybe try to get to blacks king with
King f2o Andrew cage one stuff like that
and grab a black hello he's got an extra
porn and can try a rookie 86 young
rookie a rookie six and then just take
it the pawn on d6 can only be defended
by a night which yeah can be placed on
e4 have our b5 and on both squares it
can be exchanged and then you take music
uh-huh he took the other look not so
interesting really maybe it's even
intending f5 and you for stuff like that
yeah curious not quite sure could be the
idea uh-huh yeah this I really didn't
expect but um yeah they look at this
it's not not bad at all Brooke a five
maybe now rucca five okay fate yeah I've
got nice play on f3 and nicely activated
to pieces the a black should be should
be very fine yeah this also seems fine
with Brooke everyone now covering f3
yeah but um yeah this interesting now
how does black make progress IAM it's
some certainly okay for him it's got a
knicks report and why doesn't really
have any any big play going but how do
you actually improve this position how
do you break through in a way one idea
yeah I was just about to mention this
sound would be to do something on the
queenside we've got three against two
and now two against one so we're
preparing b5 could be M could be a good
but need to be cautious be five leaves
rc5 hanging also so not clear that why
can take SF 3 is also a new it okay
hmm Wow rook takes Queen g4 I guess Oh
counter counter sacrifice just I just
ignored it so ruka three I guess
squeegee for ya Quinn Quinn g4 I think
also now and everything saying okay just
took it yeah okay it should be should be
enough also Queen g4 would have really
threatened a huge discovery in them not
sure will sure what what white would
have played but okay this must be
winning also don't think there's even a
threat but it looks a bit tricky look to
f5 maybe ok to f6 yeah this is maybe
better really threatening rook takes age
six and commit why 2022 our guests give
this check on h8 but then King f7 and
Dwight doesn't even have a check yeah
can just to capture and no route 26 and
this this is over I guess this is really
over no no idea at all yeah Queen f5 for
example not the only move by any means
but I'm Hawkwind reform yaquina five
should be enough yeah just extra piece
and yea rather easy when white resigns
yeah this was so complicated complicated
position um it's very interesting this
kind of point is this point was very
interesting I just thought I'm this one
lookie age rookie six trying to win the
pawn but he wanted to use them the look
here
I guess intending f5 really and do a
follow him already yeah I do the
intending fyf and after taking on g5
here this was was interesting g4 coming
to make user of this great bishop on c6
yeah very young very nicely played yeah
I would really like to know if this is
maurice which shall not but really hard
to tell this account is on there for a
while a very high ratings am bliss
rating is 3568 ridiculous dick Leslie I
and what is only played five minutes the
last couple of days and this was the
first game maybe there are some more
than and really a great streak here just
one loss in the last 20 games and one
draw so yeah great a great result gap
somehow there's no new game coming I
guess I'll wait down for a little bit
but them and then just wrap this video
up not quite sure something else here
maybe oops verum faciem yeah this was
meat yeah i just opened up a bullet game
he of French own grandmaster bushido
graph it's very good in bullets he
recently won a small match again sir
nakamura even
but yeah it really liked us to do five
minute to be honest but the sky is not
playing unfortunately yeah the other
five minute games are not to inspiring
young can for brief look at this year
okay we've got a new game but I want to
need to adjust oops just the board
somewhere but should the board sorry
okay okay this should be fine now so in
one night c 3 x given by igor Giro f
this is really a bit of this is a bit
similar to what tomorrow so which
actually plays yeah not quite sure yeah
so am sad lining of the french i guess
with a quick 92f for attacking you six
and wide suddenly has a very good
development here
hmm you have a nice black plays Bishop
this exam you shouldn't be too bad I
mean what is there any a problem with
the night age 54 knowledge what you
probably can just play Queen g6 yeah
probably I are interesting if you would
take with the the bishop now that's
night x e6 to BM to be checked and we
take see exactly a positional style now
the night the Knights control the square
Z five and c5 very nicely and if white
manages to get in Bishop g5 h4 g3
exchange the bishop on d6 yeah now this
one exactly and Bishop d3 then
exchanging the bishop is a really big
accomplishment as now e5 and c5 are
really weak ah interesting you took with
the f porn interesting yeah okay this is
it's really really nice now it's um it's
got the ideas of using the fr and it's
it's difficult to imagine that black can
play this position without taking on f3
at some point and then you actually have
a fine pawn structure again no double
porn
yeah this now threatens Knight to e5 and
if black would need to exchange nights
then then it's it's basically yeah
strategically very very close to our to
a lost position okay you felt inclined
to take imean now he can play you five
black must play e5 now I thought you
would take with a rock but hmm yeah no
II five this shouldn't be too bad if
Black gets an e5 now this is actually a
five minute game we had a three minute
game before with the sire bond and now
it's 5 45 minute so a bit more time to
think still I'm a bit surprised that
black is not playing a five if you're
not playing if I've now and then I know
what will go Queen III are something
similar next move and simply stop both
pawn breaks and then you will get
tortured for the rest of the game why
not just play you five it's maybe not
totally clear but you need to get rid of
this pawn I hope I'm not disconnected or
something because this is really weird
hmm looks normal yeah i just got an
excellent connection yeah I absolutely
have absolutely no idea what took him so
long for you five we have mo k maybe
this one by a but still you need to play
you five if you don't use just simply
have a terrible position for the rest of
the game
yeah c6 is so we commit them it's a it's
no it's not not much fun to play this
gather night on before is actually very
nice annoying piece I said it puts
pressure on this the seaport and also
takes d5 so you can never play c5
because d5 is a and in some lines that
maybe even taking on d5 possible to pick
up some peace that that's on fifth rank
or something like the black players
offering a draw to why this is fun
you're being being 570 points down a
minute down and position is is worse by
some degree it's not quite sure how much
but like it certainly worse yeah but I'm
also not quite sure what white is sir ok
ok this is cool so look to c 6 queen d 5
yeah then you must go rookie six and
then you're in a pin rookie one rupee
eight very interesting hmm yeah Quinn
takes rupee six yeah the first thing is
f5 but
mmm black maybe the squeem age six or
something other than Queenie sixes check
I think about h2 resins now let's buy a
check I'd ayelet so do that so just
briefly check this yeah queen bee three
actually when snow queen bee three is
winning for black Queen Essex and it's
it's curtains on our own age to like
just resigned in a winning position but
it can happen to you I mean if you play
against such a strong player you
sometimes tend to believe what they're
playing this wasn't working really queen
bee to end up black wins this is no move
no move at all h2 is so mississauga can
take you success so the show and now no
there's no move I mean this one can take
and then see you don't see any move to a
Duke of age too yeah but it sometimes
believe i'm the better player and maybe
calculate not not deep enough as you
tend to just think of right now they
will have calculated the center there's
nothing nothing left in the position and
still there is something yeah all right
he doesn't play another game and I
actually have to do something at the
here at night my place yeah thanks for
watching I think he we caught some some
fun games and yeah I'll be back soon
with with other other content down let's
say I will do something on this Bilbao
tournament if they're interesting games
um so maybe I'm tomorrow I'll be doing
something I'll be bound yeah yeah hi